-Progressives
of the Democratic Party
staged a collective
show of force
against the two Senate moderates
holding up
President Biden's agenda,
while Fox News and the GOP
resorted to increasingly
desperate rhetoric
to make it sound scary.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
You might recall that when it
came to getting things done,
the previous president
didn't always
offer a reliable timeline.
In fact, he even
kind of invented
several of his own
units of time.
-I'm getting it very soon,
within a matter of weeks.
That would be great
if we could go into the hospital
and just cure people.
And we're at a position
we're actually able to,
to a certain extent,
with what we have right now,
and we think,
in a very short period of time,
we'll be able to do that.
I'll be issuing, at some point
in the not-too-distant future,
a very strong statement on that.
-So, soon.
Why say
the "not-too-distant future"
when you could just say "soon."
Did someone set your mouth
to "Star Wars" crawl?
One of Trump's few talents
was using as many words possible
to say as little as possible.
The sentences had more filler
than an Amazon package.
"Did someone order one floss?"
Also, I love
Trump's genius insight.
In the early days
of a novel coronavirus,
we didn't fully understand
that it would be great
if we could just go into
the hospital and cure people.
It's like someone
brought their mom
into the "Grey's Anatomy's"
writers' room.
"Just have the cure ready,
and then you can focus
more on the romance.
It's why we watch."
Anyway, Donald Trump
did not offer
very specific timelines
or many specifics at all.
Everything he said
sounded like an FBI
recording of a Mafia phone call.
"The thing is done.
Let's meet back at the place
in the not-too-distant future."
"Son of a bitch!
I can't do anything with this!"
But there was
one specific length of time
Trump was very fond of citing
whenever a reporter asked
when he would do something he'd
already promised he would do.
-We're going to be announcing
something, I would say,
over the next, um,
two or three weeks.
We've got the plan
largely completed,
and we'll be filing over
the next two or three weeks.
And I'll be making a big
decision on the Paris Accord
over the next two weeks.
We're gonna be having
a news conference
in about two weeks.
I think you're gonna find
some very interesting items
coming to the forefront
over the next two weeks.
-I think,
for a con man like Trump,
two weeks is actually
the perfect time frame
because no one remembers
anything from two weeks ago.
One week, sure. But two?
By the time you're done
doing the math in your head
to figure out
when two weeks ago was,
he's already stolen your wallet.
Also, this is when I wish
"fortnight" had stuck around
as an acceptable slang
for "two weeks."
It would be great to hear a big,
dumb guy like Trump use it.
"You'll be seeing
some very interesting things
over the next fortnight,
and we hope to have
an infrastructure plan for you
and fourscore and seven days,
give or take --
give or take a score."
So, Trump never liked
to give a real timeline,
and when he did,
it was total bull[Bleep].
Compare that to Joe Biden,
who openly admits
that he doesn't really know
exactly
when Democrats will agree
on a path forward
for the $3.5 trillion
reconciliation bill.
He just knows
they'll get it done.
-President Biden trying to get
Democrats to compromise,
After a brief meeting
with House leadership,
the president seemed confident
that his $3.5 trillion
government overhaul
will get passed in Congress.
Here you can see President Biden
arriving at Capitol Hill
to meet House leadership.
He met to try to bridge
the divide between moderate
and progressive Democrats.
-When? When?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Biden has grandpa energy,
but not the kind that
gives you lots of confidence.
You ever seen an old guy at
McDonald's say to his grandkids,
"You don't want to
get out of the ball pit,
fine with me.
I can wait all day."
And you think to yourself,
"That man is going to die here."
Also, why would you say,
"six days, six weeks,
six months"?
Really? 666?
What a gift to
the red-yarn conspiracy psychos
huddled in the bowels
of Facebook.
Another contrast in styles
between Biden
and his predecessor
is how they handle
the outdoor press gaggle.
Trump, of course,
would stand on the lawn
outside a whirring helicopter,
screaming like a guy
trying to talk to his date
at a Metallica concert.
"James gets all the attention,
but Lars is really the one
who holds the band together!"
Meanwhile, Biden goes in
for the soft-talking lean-in,
as he did on Saturday,
when he was asked by reporters
what it would take
to bring Democrats together.
-Hey, man,
all things being equal,
maybe now isn't the time
for the maskless lean-in.
Even before COVID, I didn't like
when anyone got that close to me
during a conversation.
That's how a drunk guy at a bar
wants to let you know
he's serious.
"Ha-ha-ha! I love this guy!
No, but seriously, man,
I love you.
No, no, no, no, no, listen.
You are my dawg."
Progressives
flexed their muscles
by withholding the votes
for the bipartisan
infrastructure deal last week
to keep the president's
larger agenda
in the form of the $3.5 trillion
reconciliation bill alive.
The bill would address
everything from climate change
to paid family leave
to childcare.
It would pay for it
by taxing the rich.
Polls have repeatedly shown
that virtually every element
in the bill is popular,
and yet Sinema and Manchin
won't say
what they want or don't want.
In fact, they've been so opaque
about their demands,
a bunch of protesters
had to kayak out
to what Manchin calls
his houseboat to get answers.
-Several of
Senator Joe Manchin's
constituents from West Virginia
boated up to him today.
[ Chuckles ] They paddled.
They kayaked up to the houseboat
where Senator Joe Manchin lives
when he is in Washington.
Do you see him on the back
of the boat there?
They have boated themselves
up to him,
to the back of his houseboat,
to talk to him,
to plead with him
to get on board with the budget,
to get on board
with President Biden's agenda.
-But, gang, we're working on it.
We really are.
We're going to continue to,
in good faith, really.
We want to get a good bill
that's a balanced bill.
-First of all, the "Almost"
is doing a lot of work there,
a houseboat on the Potomac,
where Manchin hangs out with
people like Lindsey Graham.
He calls it "Almost Heaven,"
but I feel like a better name
would be "Most Definitely Hell."
Second, that's not a houseboat.
That's a yacht!
When you said "houseboat,"
I pictured something
a Florida crocodile hunter
would live in after his divorce.
That thing is a yacht!
And it's a pretty bad sign
for democracy
that in order to get answers
from our
elected representatives,
we have to kayak out
into a river to beg them
to shout answers down at us
from their giant boats.
Just give us
a straight answer, Joe.
At least have the same
courage of your convictions
as Schwartzy, the Pats fan
who told "Sunday Night Football"
Tom Brady's return
to New England last night.
Pats fans definitely did
a few Biden lean-ins
at the bar last night
after the game.
"Mac Jones, he's our future."
So, with the contents
of the bill being popular,
Republicans and Fox News
have had to resort
to increasingly ludicrous
rhetoric to make it sound scary,
like when Florida Senator
Marco Rubio tweeted last week,
"The $3.5 trillion Biden plan
isn't socialism, it's Marxism."
The bill would restore marginal
tax rates to early-2000 levels,
which I guess would make
George W. Bush a Marxist.
Now that you mention it,
I do remember him
at all those anti-war protests,
wearing a beret
and a Che Guevara T-shirt.
But, sure, paid family leave
and slightly higher marginal
tax rates are Marxism now.
We all remember that line
from "Das Kapital,"
when Marx said...
What happened is,
Republicans realized
the term "socialism"
lost all meaning
once they screamed it about
everything they didn't like.
So now they have to move on
to something else.
They're like desperate parents
whose kids figured out
there's no monster
who will get them at night
if they don't brush their teeth.
"There's not a monster
in my closet."
"Alright, well, a serial killer
escaped from the penitentiary,
and he is targeting children
who don't floss.
So good luck sleeping tonight."
Seems like a bunch of
the failed 2016 GOP contenders
who pathetically
fell in line behind Trump
are now coming
out of the woodwork
to slam this bill on Sunday.
Former New Jersey governor
Chris Christie
for some reason is a paid
political contributor at ABC,
despite getting fewer votes
in the primaries
than cars he's stranded on
the George Washington Bridge,
allegedly,
said the old Joe Biden
was supposedly no more.
-It's the death
of 2020 Joe Biden.
When he went to the Hill,
2020 Joe Biden is now
officially dead and buried.
The guy who ran
against the progressives,
ran against Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren,
ran to be a uniter
in this country,
ran saying he was
going to force compromise,
and he went up
to Capitol Hill
and he capitulated
to the progressives,
the liberals in his party.
-Sure, he ran against
Bernie and Warren,
but you ran against Trump
and ended up standing behind him
at every press conference
like Doody at Thunder Road.
[ Chuckles ]
Fresh raff.
Again, a week from today,
audiences are back,
and bye-bye, Doody.
[ Laughter ]
You said Trump wasn't "suited"
to be president,
and then you ended up following
him around like a seagull
chasing a potato chip
at the Jersey Shore.
If 2020 Joe Biden
is officially dead and buried,
then what happened
to 2015 Chris Christie?
Is he buried in the sand
on a private beach?
-We do not need reality TV
in the Oval Office, everybody.
What's that tell you
about what we can expect
if things go sideways when
you go into the Oval Office?
What are you gonna do?
Just go upstairs
to the residence
and say, "I'm not playing"?
You know, "Vladimir Putin
isn't being nice to me.
I'm not gonna return
his phone call.
The press isn't
being nice to me.
I'm not gonna hold
any more press conferences"?
I mean, basically,
this is like --
this is like
a 13-year-old argument.
-Personally, I am shocked
to look at these old clips
and discover that a man
as principled as Chris Christie
would change his mind
for political expediency.
You know how hard we had to dig
to find these clips?
Our research team had to sift
through microfiche
in the basement
of 30 Rock for days,
scouring dusty cans of film,
poring over old transcripts,
and -- What's that?
These clips
are all over the Internet,
and they're easy to find?
When you type "C" into Google,
It autofills to Chris Christie
criticizing Donald Trump
before he forgave him and became
his unrequited best friend?
But I have to say,
probably the grossest
and most detestable criticisms
of this bill
have come from right-wing
media personalities
complaining that if we
help people too much
with things like childcare
and paid family leave,
they will become
dependent on it.
-Senator, here's what --
here's what I fear, though.
If you tell someone,
"I'm giving you free preschool,"
if you tell someone, "I'm giving
you free junior college,"
if you tell someone, "I'm gonna
give you free school lunch,"
if you tell someone
"free eldercare,"
issues need to be addressed,
yes,
but if you write
all those people a check,
you've got their votes.
And we're sitting there
and have to balance the books.
Doesn't that worry you?
-There's no work requirements.
And in fact, Sean, there's
no education requirements.
So you've got
massive welfare dependency.
It's like the Great Society
to the, I don't know,
20th or 50th power.
But that will damage
the soul of America.
-It's a common-sense argument,
and I think you're right.
One of the things that kills me
is that now that -- you know,
there's a free-lunch program
in New Jersey
and it's for everyone,
even if you you don't need help
to send your child's lunch
to school.
So those kids are all
gonna grow up
thinking, "Well, school lunch
is free," right?
And then God help the person
who comes along
and tries to take that away,
Larry.
-I don't know, man.
When I was a kid,
they gave me a math book,
and I didn't go through life
thinking books were free.
I'm pretty sure you learn
the difference as you get older.
You don't show up to a first day
on the job and ask,
"When do you guys have recess?"
A lot of stuff happens in school
that stops once school ends.
You're never asked to
climb a rope in short shorts,
and you never have
to play kickball
unless you move to L.A.
I don't know.
That's like 90 minutes
away from me with traffic.
And if I'm being honest,
it sounds like it sucks.
It's so revealing
what shocks these people.
If Congress wanted to spend
$10 trillion tomorrow
to send those creepy
Boston Dynamics robots
to the border,
they wouldn't bat an eye.
But give a child
a free lunch at school,
and they freak out
like their butler
just mixed up the salad fork
and the oyster fork.
I wouldn't be surprised
if they said,
"They can have their free lunch
if they can get
by the Boston Dynamics robot,"
which I don't think
is that hard.
I think you just play,
"Do You Love Me,"
and they have to dance.
"You must pass me
to receive your tater tots."
[ "Do You Love Me" plays ]
-♪ Do you love me?"
-♪ I can really move ♪
-"No, no, no, no."
-♪ I'm in the groove ♪
-♪ Now, do you love me? ♪
[ Laughter ]
-How much did that song cost?
Oh, that was a --
That was a mistake.
The progressives
in the Democratic Party
finally flexed their muscles
and showed
that the corporate-backed
centrists
don't get to call all the shots.
The things they're asking for
are already compromises.
There are things
that should be automatic
in a decent, humane society,
like dental coverage for seniors
or paid family leave,
not to mention
the massive urgency
of tackling climate change.
Meanwhile, Republicans
at Fox News
are losing their minds
and acting like helping people
pay for childcare
is some kind of sci-fi dystopia
set in the...
-Not-too-distant future.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over 2 million
meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.